hey everyone it's megan traynor merry
christmas happy holidays i'm very
excited i have a new christmas album
coming out a very trainer christmas
and to celebrate i'm with buzzfeed today
and we're doing a bunch of holiday
quizzes if you want to try to take the
quizzes
the link is right here down below click
it it's really fun it's really fun to
find out what kind of cookie you are
i'm so excited
[Music]
the first quiz i'm gonna take is which
christmas food has to go
okay the first question which christmas
we must go we got yule log
christmas pudding
i'm not this boosty i don't i don't see
any of these in my christmas table
i can't pronounce that one so i'm gonna
pick pinatone
oh i picked a good one everyone said 48
said that one's got to go
roast turkey roast beef roast pork with
crackling these are so
fancy the honestly the rose pork on the
right looks pretty yummy
roast turkey's a must i'm gonna go roast
beef 28
average potatoes stuffing
and pigs in a blanket these are all
excellent
if i was stranded on an island and i had
to pick one to go i'm picking
stuffing to go because pig's in a
blanket too good potatoes are a must
i'm an average gal 40 of you okay
mince pies candy canes and christmas
cookies
well i need christmas cookies it's a
need
and i need candy canes so i'm gonna pick
means pies i'm also not this fancy don't
have this food
61 does this mean i'm like normal mold
wine
eggnog and peppermint hot chocolate she
is pregnant so we don't get to have none
of this but
peppermint hot chocolate looks good
eggnog is good mold wine i'm sure is
lovely
i've never had it i'm gonna pick that
one i'm an average gal 38
of us agree we have gravy bread sauce
and cranberry sauce i've never had bread
sauce
i like bread and i like sauce but that
doesn't make sense to me i'm gonna pick
bread sauce 69 hello
trifle christmas cake and pavlova
never had any of these in my life i mean
christmas cake that's just like a good
cake
bye papa i was right 47 say bye blah
blah blah
roast chestnuts nut roast
or clementines love a clementine love
nuts
what's a nut roast what do you say you
sprinkle that
it's gotta go 61 this is the last one
which christmas food must go we're at
chocolates oh celebrations why am i so
lame that i don't even know these
selection boxes oh chocolate event
calendars are
so good we're keeping those we're
keeping the celebrations because they
just look like good packaging
selection boxes that was pretty accurate
pretty normal gal
nothing crazy for christmas but also we
gotta get fancier on our desserts we
gotta learn how to bake
so my next quiz i'm gonna do is are
these christmas songs great or totally
awful
jingle bells i mean this is a delight i
love this song
39 people are kind of over it okay
we wish you a merry christmas that's a
yes these are like i'm in school
we're singing them in the classroom
we're having a good time we wish
you know what yes you're fine 57 percent
okay i'm getting this i'm getting this
deck the homes how's that
kind of annoying like if there's an
annoying button i'd pick this but
i have no strong feelings either way i
love these answers
56 silent night
it's a classic it's very good i covered
this on my album check it out
i'm gonna say i love this song it's so
beautiful that's the button i'm gonna
click
aha we all love it 55 yes the next one
is frosty the snowman
it's the classic it's not annoying at
all i'm going to say yes
a lot of mess a lot of men's out there
46 minutes but like
40 yes so we're right there we're
holding on strong have yourself a merry
little christmas
another very well written song great
lyrics great melodies
another one i covered on my christmas
album check it out my holiday album
i'm going to say i love this song
exclamation point 58
thank god okay all i want for christmas
is you
get out of here this song is perfect
praise be to mariah
this is the best answer i'm gonna pick
the first one this song is perfect
76 she'll never lose she's the best
she's the queen of all christmas white
christmas i love this song i wonder how
people think about this song
i really like this song another one i
covered beach drinks
seth macfarlane this song is lovely 51
rudolph the red-nosed reindeer another
tune on my cool
album i'm gonna say because i had my
cousin's feature on it was so sweet and
adorable i'm gonna say
is so good 42 but it's okay because like
i would not go out of my way to turn it
off is 49
jingle bell jingle bell jingle bell rock
so good
it's like the jingle bells but it rocks
a plus plus
i'm thinking that 63 last christmas
another one i did yes this one's perfect
a true classic rp george michael 100
every single day 70 percent that's my
mom's favorite
rock it around the christmas tree so
good i'm gonna say this song rules
56 percent feliz navidad
yeah that's great this song is wonderful
that's the only time i feel like mom
speak in spanish
wonderful 54 look at that the 12 days of
christmas
very interesting cool song that is very
impressive
as a songwriter it's very impressive no
one could pull that off today ever
do i want to sing it all day long no
why why would anyone write a song like
this
oh my god i don't want to hit that
button it's hard i'm gonna say it's okay
i guess because i feel bad
oh 46 the most okay and we're all the
same
santa claus is coming to town yeah this
one's great this
tells you the rules of how christmas
works very clear oh yeah
baby that's what i'm hitting 54 i'm just
like everybody else
winter wonderland this one's so good i
covered this one as well with my ukulele
played it before i got the claws on
lovely tuna chew classic
i'm hitting that 63 percent it's the
most wonderful time
of the year that was pretty good i
tolerated i loathe it
i tolerate it 32 percent
what's this silver bells i forgot about
this song too
how does it go besides silver bells
silver bells
i'm gonna do the cute little and we're
correct 55
i saw mommy kissing santa claus i don't
like the message of this song
this song is bad and this kid is a
creepy i'm going to say the song is bad
37
38 say sigh i can deal with it i don't
like the message of it
i saw mom cheating on dad with santa oh
dad santa
oh i'm so embarrassing you know what now
it's cute
last quiz i'm taking eat your way
through this holiday buffet and we'll
reveal which type of cookie you are
i had to do this because i know i feel
like i'm a sugar cookie
it's gotta be sugar cookie first load
your plate
with an entree turkey ham lasagna yes
yes steak salmon stuffed mushrooms see
i'm the gal that will pick all of these
and will make the cutest little plate of
all entrees
i pick ham pick your first side dish
green bean casserole nah brussels
sprouts
oh mashed potatoes always cranberry
sauce
and macaroni and cheese and bread with
butter well that's hard
i would do macaroni cheese bread my
butter brussels sprouts mashed potatoes
but i'll just pick one
mashed potatoes pick another side dish
here we go mix green beans
mashed potatoes peas pasta oh
my plate would be so dirty if i really
had these options garlic mashed potatoes
what or could carrots okay i'm gonna try
to
look like a better person so i'm gonna
pick cooked carrots
choose something for dessert well
brownies red velvet cake chocolate cake
vanilla cupcake cheesecake not a big
cheesecake gal
fruit cake blue my wedding cake was a
red velvet cake
because it's delicious yes it was one of
my cakes i also had oreo ice cream cause
i'm bougie okay i'm gonna pick red
velvet cake
now you know you want a cookie too so
pick one i've never had a gingerbread
cookie that sounds sad
crushed candy cane cookie never have
that sugar cookie yeah that's my main
peanut butter chocolate green and red m
m cookies
adorable but jam thumb print cookie that
looks too fancy for me
i'm going suga choose a holiday drink i
won't be allowed to have
because i'm pregnant champagne gives me
headaches red sangria
don't know if i've ever had it spiked
eggnog i had it once it was fine
i don't want to know what's in that hot
toddy love
didn't know that was a christmas thing i
just had them like all the time
mold wine again i don't know what that
is moscow mule or that's if you're like
going out to the clubs all night
i'm gonna do a virgin hot toddy
finally what topping do you inevitably
have to scrape off your plate
back at the table okay i didn't want to
eat that we got tomatoes
lettuce cilantro thyme basil or
mushrooms
so i'm going to pick tomato because i
don't see that being in anything so i'm
going to pick an easy one
[Music]
i'm a snickerdoodle they look bomb
i could i can get into that you're a
snickerdoodle cookie
you have an incredibly big heart i love
this you're constantly making sure
everyone around you feels included and
welcome
how do they know you love throwing
parties
no because it gives you a chance to have
your various friend groups meet
oh you're empathetic caring and sincere
this is so accurate it's insane oh my
god this is so nice
i'm a snickerdoodle what's up wow
i loved these tests i can't stop smiling
my cheeks hurt that was so sweet and fun
don't forget i got a holiday album
coming out i'm very trained at christmas
thank you buzzfeed for the support and
love and thanks for letting me take your
[Music]
quizzes
you